oh
bonjour à tous cet après midi les
discussions reprennent à l'article 11 du
projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites
un article qui porte sur l'âge de départ
à la retraite des fonctionnaires
le contexte social dans lequel s'inscrit
et cet examen reste toujours très tendue
demain est prévu une journée de
mobilisation et puis encore une autre
mardi prochain à la veille du vote
solennel sur la réforme des retraites
même si cette date risque d'être
difficile à tenir parce que l'examen du
texte s'effectue très lentement ce matin
à l'elysée a ordonné le déblocage de
trois dépôts de carburant
malgré cela c'est un secteur qui reste
très perturbée par les grèves
et puis par ailleurs la mobilisation
lycéenne continue sur un fond de crainte
des débordements et d'ailleurs le préfet
de paris a suspendu pour l'instant
l'utilisation des flashball tout de
suite direction l'hémicycle pour la
suite de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites de la suppression de
l'ensemble des alinéas de l'article nous
réaffirmons notre opposition à
l'ensemble du dispositif de cet article
pour vous convaincre
je voudrais aborder la question des
emplois classés en catégorie active dans
la fonction publique hospitalière il
s'agit là de métiers particulièrement
stressant éprouvant physiquement je ne
m'étendrai pas sur ce point puisque
plusieurs de mes collègues l'ont
amplement démontré alors que le
gouvernement s'était engagé
je fais référence à l'engagement numéro
9 du gouvernement sur les retraites âge
site tenir compte de ceux qui ont eu une
vie professionnelle plus difficile cet
engagement entre en totale contradiction
au détriment des salariés avec
l'objectif affiché lors de l'examen du
projet de loi portant rénovation du
dialogue social et anticipant les débats
sur les retraites le gouvernement a par
un cavalier législatif est passé de 55
ans à 60 60 ans l'âge de retraite de
départ à la retraite des infirmiers et
personnel
à rennes-ii qu en échange du versement
de ces derniers dans la catégorie a de
la fonction publique avec les sénateurs
de mon groupe nous avions proposé au
contraire de reconnaître la qualité et
l'engagement des professionnels par une
double revalorisation au travers d'une
part de la qualification et d'autre part
de la gratification
aujourd'hui nos divergences sont
toujours les mêmes nous considérons que
les emplois visés notamment en raison de
la pénibilité ne peuvent faire l'objet
d'un enlèvement des limites d'âge mais
parce que l'article 14 du projet de loi
s'inscrit dans la droite ligne de cette
première atteintes portées au statut des
infirmiers du public face à la
dégradation des conditions de travail
dans le public comme dans le privé à la
remise en cause de la reconnaissance de
la pénibilité pour l'ensemble des
professionnels du secteur de la santé et
au nom de la défense des droits de
l'ensemble des salariés des catégories
actives de la fonction publique nous
nous vous demandons de voter pour cet
amendement merci jacques collègue
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission amendements donc avis
défavorable de la commission sous
ministre défavorable il est favorable
pas de demandes d'explications de vote
que ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veuille bien levé la
main il n'est pas adopté a maintenant
789 il est présenté par madame est celle
ci pardon par monsieur fille fait
monsieur le président oui par cet
amendement dans le droit fil des
positions nous avons défendu
nous sommes opposés au passage de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite de syncope
devant lorsqu'elle était fixé
antérieurement à 57 ans pour les agents
de la fonction publique les à compter du
1er janvier 66 alors cette date limite
cette limite d'âge concerne
particulièrement
barbie il ya un certain nombre de
catégories les ingénieurs du contrôle de
la navigation aérienne
pourtant ces personnels subissent des
conditions de travail dont la pénibilité
est un caractérisée est reconnue cela
justifie d'ailleurs un départ précoce et
un aménagement de leur temps de travail
les contrôleurs aériens souvent appelée
aiguilleurs du ciel ont en effet pour
mission d'assurer le contrôle et la
sécurité et la gestion de la circulation
aérienne
il s'agit d'une mission d'intérêt
général fondamentale source d'un grand
stress chez les contrôleurs compte tenu
du développement du mode de transport
aérien voire de l'explosion des trafics
en effet la moindre erreur pourrait
avoir des conséquences particulièrement
dramatique l'importance du trafic les
conditions météo les plans de vol des
trajectoires des avions
voilà de nombreuses informations que le
contrôleur doit analyser simultanément
et doit ainsi être en mesure de réagir
et de prendre des décisions avec une
extrême rapidité
plus fondamentalement leur métier et
éprouvant lourde responsabilité comme le
pilote le contrôleur aérien tient la vie
de tous les occupants d'un avion entre
ses mains il doit donc en être en
parfaite condition physique et surtout
nerveuse quoi il communique bien sûr en
anglais avec les pilotes dans la plupart
des cas ils travaillent en horaires
décalés le service fonctionne quant à
jemeppe a dit sam se munissent attention
de caricaturer pas mes positions
mais si vous en êtes d'accord allons-y
au ces conditions de travail
particulièrement pénible et justifiant
un départ anticipé n'ont pas changé bien
au contraire
le trafic étant de plus en plus
important les conditions donc mérite
d'être regardé de très près c'est pour
cela que nous demandons le maintien de
leur âge légal de départ à la retraite à
57 ans et cela pour deux raisons
préserver les droits sociaux des
contrôleurs aériens mais parce que nous
considérons que maintenir dans l'emploi
ces contrôleurs trop tard pourrait faire
peser des risques importants sur la
bonne réalisation de leur mission de
sécurité
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission avis
défavorable de la commission aura
monsieur ministre l'avis du gouvernement
avis défavorable sur et hors amm pas
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veuille bien levé la
main amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement 790 mhz à damas et 6 merci
monsieur le président la lina l'alinéa 4
de cet article traite des fonctionnaires
dont la limite d'âge était jusqu'à lors
fixé à 58 ans pour la relever à 60 ans
alors bon cela ne saurait vous étonner
nous souhaitons supprimer cet
allongement
nous sommes ainsi en cohérence avec les
amendements précédent déposée sur cet
article
comme sur l'ensemble du texte le
dispositif donc que vous nous proposez
est selon nous il date inadaptée et
contradictoires et je vais si vous tapez
était maintenant vous donner les
paramètres qui nous permettent
pour ce qui nous concerne d'aboutir à
cette conclusion
premièrement seuls 40 % des 55 64 ans
ont un emploi
l'emploi de ce que l'on appelle des
seniors est difficile et nombre d'entre
eux terminent leur carrière par des
années de chômage
deuxièmement favoriser l'emploi des
seniors contribuera à augmenter celui
des jeunes
ce sont autant de postes qui ne seront
pas occupées par de nouveaux entrants
sur le marché du travail troisièmement
le chômage des jeunes est déjà
extrêmement important et vous le savez
est aujourd'hui évalué à 25% des jeunes
de moins de 25 ans en âge de travailler
quatrièmement le chômage comme les
retraites a un coût financier qui
incombe à l'état
en plus de son coût social alors comment
le gouvernement peut-il ainsi prévoir de
reculer l'âge limite du départ à la
retraite sont par ailleurs se soucier de
la question de l'emploi réel des seniors
ces deux questions se complète sous
peine de devenir une efficace ou
d'appauvrir nos futurs retraités
condamnés à des années de chômage
supplémentaires au risque que celles ci
soient prises en compte dans le montant
de leur pension selon la branche chômage
de la sécurité sociale l'unedic
le coût de la réforme des retraites sur
l'assurance chômage sera serait pardon
colossal
les chiffres ont déjà été évoqués mais
je me fais un petit plaisir pour les
rappeler ici parce qu'ils sont tout
simplement significatif la réforme des
retraites va creuser le déficit de
l'assurance chômage de cartes sont 40 à
530 millions d'euros par an à partir de
2017 voilà donc les raisons de notre
refus du recul de la limite d'âge de
départ à la retraite qui dans la
fonction publique comme ailleurs
n'aura pour effet que d'alimenter le
chômage des jeunes particulièrement en
difficulté par la diminution du nombre
de places aux concours qui a lié à la
rgpp sera drastiques
c'est pourtant bien l'emploi qui
constitue une des ressources principales
de la sécurité sociale en matière de
financement des retraites par le biais
de la cotisation des actifs alors le
cercle vicieux des dispositifs prévus
par le gouvernement est bouclée puisque
les mesures prévues alimenteront
purement et simplement le déficit des
comptes de l'état et voilà pourquoi
j'espère avoir été clair nous demandons
donc la suppression de cet alinéa comme
de ceux d'ailleurs qui vont suivre parce
qu'il s'agit pour nous de quelque chose
de fondamentalement important merci cher
collègue monsieur rapporteur l'avis de
la commission avis défavorable pour la
suppression de l'alinéa 4
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre à vie gouvernement ni dans
défavorable pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement va
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté le 791 monsieur
d'englos le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
l'alinéa 5 de l'article 14 repousse à 61
non l'âge de départ à la retraite sans
pénalisation pour les agents nés à
compter du 1er janvier 1962 s'agissant
des emplois classe en catégorie active
vous n'avez de cesse de parler d'équité
entre public et privé
quand en réalité vous chercher à
économiser sur le régime des
fonctionnaires en l'alignant sur le
privé car pour vous s'agissant des
salariés
l'équité ne peut se concrétiser que vers
le bas vous chercher sans cesse à
opposer les salariés du privé à ceux du
secteur public
tentant de faire passer ces derniers
pour d'indécent privilégiées
c'est une constante dans de votre
politique diviser pour régner
mais une constante qui fonctionne de
moins
en moins bien il n'est qu'à voir comment
se côtoient dans les manifestations
toute la diversité des secteurs publics
comme privés le tous ensemble saône
l'échec cinglant de vos campagnes de
division ce que nous défendons c'est une
véritable égalité devant le droit à la
retraite et nous n'oublions pas que
c'est pour commencer la réforme balladur
de 1993 qui a précisément creuser les
inégalités entre les différents régimes
en portant la période de référence de 10
ans à 25 ans pour le calcul des pensions
dans le privé et en allongeant la durée
de cotisation de 2 37 ans et demi à 40
ans vous avez définitivement installé le
déséquilibre entre le secteur privé et
le secteur public
puis au nom d'une prétendue écrite et
vous avez dénoncé ce déséquilibre est
dans la réforme de 2003 a accru la durée
de cotisation des fonctionnaires pour
prétendre à la retraite en l'alignant
sur le privé en conséquence aujourd'hui
vous augmenter l'âge de départ à la
retraite et et la limite d'âge de tout
le monde à égalité deux ans vous
manifestez une singulière conception de
l'équité et de l'égalité une conception
pour le moins partisane vers le bas pour
l'énorme majorité des salariés et vers
le haut pour les dirigeants de grandes
entreprises pour lesquelles les
retraites s'apparente à une pêche
miraculeuse qu'ils viennent de la
fonction publique ou du secteur privé
les salariés ne sont pas monsieur le
ministre responsable de l'insuffisance
de financement des retraites
ce sont vos politiques inégalitaires
antisocial qui le sont nous refusons
donc toute augmentation de la limite
d'âge pour les fonctionnaires en service
actif
nous demandons la suppression don de cet
alinéa 5 est si cher collègue monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis de la commission
nouvelles suppressions donc avis
défavorable défavorable monsieur
ministre à vis du gouvernement est
favorable ce président défavorable 1
explications de vote
n'ai pas d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
avait bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veut bien levé la main
il n'est pas adopté un amendement 792 tu
sais pas si ça marche pas monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'alinéa 6 de l'article
14 que nous vous proposons de supprimer
repousse à 62 ans l'âge de départ à la
retraite sans minoration pour les agents
nés à compter du 1er janvier 1961 il
s'agit des emplois a cassé en catégorie
active et je souhaiterais rappeler ce
que sont les emplois de fonctionnaires
classés en catégorie active
il s'agit de ceux présentant un risque
particulier ou des fatigues
exceptionnelles augmenté donc dans la
loi l'âge de départ à la retraite c'est
rayer d'un trait de plume cette
particularité c'est ne pas tenir compte
du fait que risques particuliers ou
fatigues exceptionnelles
cela signifie probabilité de diminution
de l'espérance de vie ce qui montre s'il
était encore nécessaire que votre
assistance sur ce critère de l'espérance
de vie n'est qu'un prétexte
les femmes seront ici particulièrement
touchée puisque nous savons bien que
dans la fonction publique comme ailleurs
nombre d'entre elles touchent des
salaires faibles elles ont aussi des
carrières amputé par des périodes prise
par exemple pour élever les enfants
beaucoup seront obligés de travailler
durant ces deux ans supplémentaires pour
ne pas percevoir une pension davantage
minorés vous allez finalement pénalisé
les fonctionnaires plusieurs fois en
allongeant la durée de cotisation en
augmentant le montant des cotisations et
en diminuant dans le même temps le
montant de leur retraite
là encore au nom d'une prétendue équité
quelques mots sur l'augmentation des
cotisations qui je le souligne atteindre
à 34,93 % en dix ans elle se traduira
nécessairement par une nouvelle baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des fonctionnaires
ce n'est pourtant pas protides propice à
une relance du pays
pourtant nécessaires pour lutter contre
le chômage et donc pour faire entrer des
cotisations d'autre part elle repose
votre affirmation selon laquelle les
fonctionnaires paieraient moins que les
salariés du privé c'est faux le taux de
cotisation des agents de la fonction
publique est de 7,85 % celui des
salariés du privé et de 6,65 pour la
cotisation vieillesse plafonné plus 0,1
pour cent pour celles dé plafonner soit
6 75 quand vous évoquez un taux de 10 55
vous omettez de dire que ce pourcentage
intègre la cotisation pour la retraite
complémentaire des salariés du privé
dont ne bénéficient pas le secteur
public
quel que soit le bout par lequel on
prenne l'article 14 il constitue dans
toutes ses déclinaisons une régression
que nous combattons c'est la raison de
notre demande de suppression
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
l'avis de la commission
oui monsieur le président nouvelles
suppressions dans l'avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre la ville
favorable ou défavorable pas deux
explications de vote madame autexier
merci monsieur le président en fait eu
une question me taraude depuis depuis ce
matin lorsque l'on parle d'espérance de
vie donnée statistique qu'ils aient à
l'instant madame hermange donc
irréfutables
dont acte données statistiques donc
irréfutables la question qui me taraude
est la suivante plusieurs fois ce matin
le ministre nous a élégamment renvoyé
dans nos buts à chaque fois que nous
essayons de demander le maintien de la
pénibilité pour les infirmières en nous
disant l'espérance de vie des
infirmières est équivalente voire
légèrement supérieur à l'espérance de
vie d'une femme lambda je voudrais
savoir pourquoi cet argument d'espérance
de vie équivalente nous est renvoyée
pour réfuter nos arguments lorsqu'il
s'agit de ce cas précis d'experts des
espérances de vie équivalente et des
infirmières et pourquoi lorsque nous
vous disons ce qui a été le cas la
semaine dernière dix fois vingt fois
cent fois que l'espérance de vie des
ouvriers et cette fois inférieure à
celle des cadres vous ne voulez pas nous
entendre et là aussi vous nous renvoyez
dans le but en ne prenant pas en compte
nos amendements qui nous demande de
maintenir l'âge de la retraite à 60 ans
et à 65 ans j'aimerais bien avoir une
réponse
je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement avait
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté un
amendement 793 il est présenté par
monsieur vers un merci le sub résidents
l'alinéa 7 de l'article 14 repousse à 64
ans l'âge de départ à la retraite sans
minoration pour les agents appartenant
aux catégories actives de la fonction
publique est né à compter du 1er janvier
1960 et de cet alinéa 7 comme l'ensemble
de l'article 14 participe de la remise
en cause progressive des droits attachés
au service actif
ces droits sont pourtant reconnus depuis
plusieurs décennies au regard
précisément des difficultés inhérentes
aux missions concernés c'est donc une
nouvelle régression sociale
que vont subir les fonctionnaires comme
le reste des salariés et à vous entendre
les fonctionnaires seraient responsables
de la situation de leur régime de
retraite
il ne travaillerait pas assez longtemps
et ne cotiseraient pas assez vous
omettez de dire qu'avec la rgpp la
fonction publique perd chaque année de
très nombreux cotisants aux régimes de
retraite et vous refuser d'en tenir
compte dans vos calculs alors que cela
pèse et pèsera à terme encore plus
lourdement sur les financements
on en arrive même à ce qu'au pôle emploi
les effectifs connaissent une décrue
face à la croissance du nombre de
chômeurs permettez moi d'ailleurs une
question dans la mesure où vous voulez
allonger la durée du travail des
fonctionnaires de deux ans comptez vous
encore réduire les remplacements des
départs en retraite au nom du dogme donc
de la réduction des dépenses publiques
allez vous augmenter encore le nombre de
jeunes susceptibles de travailler dans
la fonction publique mais qui y
trouveront porte close
je vous rappelle que 23% des jeunes
actifs sont au chômage
mais votre obsession c'est de réduire la
réponse publique aux besoins des
populations pour y substituer une
réponse privé d'ailleurs la réforme des
collectivités locales avec laquelle vous
êtes d'ailleurs aujourd'hui dans
l'impasse a pour vocation de satisfaire
cet objectif tous convergent dons pour
montrer que cette réforme ne règlera les
problèmes de financement des retraites
ni à l'horizon 2018
ni à un autre ce n'est d'ailleurs pas
son objet la population les salariés
l'ont bien compris
vous avez sur ce point perdu la bataille
des idées
vous avez perdu la bataille de l'opinion
l'immense majorité des salariés la
population et la grande majorité des
jeunes rejettent votre réforme
tous refusent de travailler deux ans de
plus merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de la
commission
encore une nouvelle suppression c'est
aussi de l'alinéa 7 donc avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
la vidéo et même avis
dino même avis défavorable pas de
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement va
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veuille bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté nous votons sur
l'article 14
explications de vote mal à conclure
merci monsieur le président ma qui me
lis mes chers collègues
l'article 14 entend donc relevé de deux
années des limites d'âge des
fonctionnaires appartenant aux
catégories actives de la fonction
publique
cet article ne comporte que des reculs
sur le droit de ses salariés sans la
moindre proposition positive qui tient
compte de l'évolution de notre société
nous jugeons ce relèvement d'âge injuste
et absolument impropre à constituer une
réponse aux défis que présente la
pérennisation de nos régimes de retraite
limite d'âge fixée ici correspondent à
des activités ou des tâches qui ont été
jugées comme pénibles et alors même que
le gouvernement prétend mettre en place
un dispositif sur la pénibilité dans le
secteur privé très insuffisants au
demeurant à nos yeux il remet en cause
celui existant dans la fonction publique
la vie au travail nous l'avons dit
toutes ces jours derniers et ses heures
dernière est difficile en particulier
pour certains métiers
la souffrance au travail se développe et
de nouvelles pathologies apparaissent
aussi en cohérence avec l'ensemble des
propos que nous avons tenues depuis lé
début de l'examen de ce tête de ce texte
nous nous opposons à cette disposition
merci chers collègues
explications de vote monsieur fisher sur
le président je voudrais pas prolonger
mais vous comprendrez que par souci de
cohérence et tous les arguments qui ont
été développés à travers nos amendements
et bien montre que là on va à la remise
en cause de droits acquis importants et
on ne tient pas compte des réalités donc
le gouvernement est bien dans on avait
vu qu'il y avait un certain nombre
d'amendements emblématique 1 c'était les
articles 4 5 et 6 et bien là bien sûr le
gouvernement est cohérent avec sa
position mais le relèvement de deux
années des limites d'âge des catégories
actives de la preuve de la fonction
publique
je rappelle que cela touche 22 groupes
d'emplois dans le rapport de la
commission il y a un tableau très bien
fait qui identifie clairement quelles
sont les personnes concernées est donc
bien entendu nous maintenons est plus
que jamais cette volonté de supprimer
cet article 14
c'est pour cela que j'ai demandé un
scrutin public merci cher collègue
monsieur longuet pour explication de
vote
oui merci monsieur le président
missionné miss mes chers collègues une
courte explication de vote pour soutenir
naturellement cet article et répondent
un autre excellent collègue jean-pierre
sueur qui tournait en dérision l'effort
d'optimisation des moyens des
fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie
vous avez chaque collègue gérer une
grande ville je crois vous avez géré les
collectivités locales dans les
responsabilités ministérielles
comment pouvez vous imaginer qu'un corps
de fonctionnaires de l'état qui ensemble
représentent près de 250 mille agents ne
puisse pas sur une période de trois ans
dégager un gain de productivité de 9000
personnel ce qui représente un effort de
productivité de l'ordre de 1% par an si
la fonction publique n'est pas en mesure
de se remettre en cause pour dégager une
productivité de 1 % par an alors que
nous savons les uns et les autres pour
gérer nous mêmes des services importants
qu'au fur et à mesure des années de
mauvaise procédure d'une part l'absence
d'utilisation de moyens modernes d'autre
part aboud la duplication des efforts
aboutissent parfois à des sureffectifs
c'est de l'optimisation des moyens qui
est parfaitement à la portée d'un grand
d'un gestionnaire normal d'une très
grande administration
un des gués à notre collègue fischer qui
a évoqué la situation des contrôleurs
aériens qui l'a oublié de traiter une
demande qui d'ailleurs a été repoussée
je crois par l'autorité administrative
d'un syndicat de contrôleurs aériens qui
souhaitait pouvoir prolonger la
profession dès l'âge de limites
d'activité des contrôleurs aériens
considérant que les conditions normales
et les comptes technique d'une part avec
les conditions physiques contrôle et
d'autre part permettait aux contrôleurs
aériens qui en auraient exprimé la
demande de pouvoir prolonger leur
activité
j'ajoute pour prolonger pour évoquer un
sujet qui était traitée hier soir d'où
viennent pour l'essentiel les
conducteurs de locomotive des
exploitants privés du réseau français
ils viennent en général des retraités de
la sncf
voilà je voulais simplement rappeler
quelques évidences merci chers collègues
je n'ai pas d'autres demandes
d'explications de vote j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe crc spg sur l'article 14 du
projet de loi il va être procédé
je rappelle donc que l'avis de la
commission est favorable à vis du
gouvernement est favorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
l'article remettront secrétaire un
bulletin blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter
contre l'article remettront un bulletin
bleu ce qui soit s'abstenir remettront
un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
résultat du scrutin numéro de 37 sur
l'article 14 du projet de loi portant
réforme des retraites nombre de votants
338 nombre de suffrages exprimés 336
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
169 pour l'adoption 183 contre 153 le
sénat a adopté
nous en arrivons à l'article 15 ch et
une demande de parole de madame le
texier ici chez président ministres mes
chers collègues transférer des charges
pour faire croire que que l'on maîtrise
ses coûts est une technique de gestion
inefficace et dangereuse et vous allez
les faits une méthode de gouvernement
inopérante et destructrice cet article
15 illustre votre démarche en la matière
en relevant les âges limite de versement
des indemnités aux travailleurs privés
d'emploi dans les mêmes conditions que
les bornes d'âge en matière de retraites
le gouvernement organise concrètement la
transformation de jeunes retraités en
vieux chômeurs à l'assurance-chômage de
prendre le relais de ce qui relevait de
la retraite
les nouveaux chômeurs et perdront ce que
les employeurs et gagneront chacun sait
en effet que les indemnités liées au
chômage sont plus réduites moins
pérennes et surtout moins coûteuse pour
les entreprises
avec seulement 17 % des 60 64 ans dans
l'emploi on mesure à quel point le
relèvement des bornes d'âge va peser sur
les comptes de l'unedic plus d'un
milliard d'euros sur la période 2015
2017 l'a déjà été dit voilà le résultat
de l'impact de votre réforme sur les
comptes de l'unedic
l'impact sur les hommes et les femmes
qui seront concernées n'est pas
seulement quantitatif bien sûr les
conséquences de cet article seront
mauvaises pour leurs finances et elles
seront encore pires
pour leur moral alors que rien n'est
fait pour favoriser le maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors alors qu'aucune
réflexion n'a été amorcée pour mettre en
place une autre politique d âge au sein
de l'entreprise comme dans notre société
vous choisissez de livrer aux affres de
la fin de droits ce qui n'aspirait qu'à
vivre enfin de leur retraite
loin de mobiliser tous les outils pour
remettre la question de l'emploi au
coeur de la problématique de la gestion
du vieillissement vous fait l'aumône
d'une aide à l'embauché des plus de 55
ans et d'un discours sur le tutorat
dépourvu de toute mesure concrète
j'en veux pour preuve cette palinodie
que constitue l'obligation affiché pour
les entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
d'avoir conclu un accord ou mis en place
un plan d'action pour leurs salariés
seniors soumis à aucune sanction
n'ayant fait l'objet d'aucun débat ne
nous donnant lieu à aucune mesure
concrète il est cache misère de la
désertion de ce gouvernement
sur le front de l'emploi des seniors
dommage car d'autres ont su se battre
sur ce front là et ont obtenu des
résultats dans les pays nordiques
l'effort a notamment porté sur le
relèvement du taux d'emploi des
quinquagénaires la question de la
valorisation de ce patrimoine humain les
amener à mettre en place une politique
globale axée sur le maintien de
l'employabilité de leurs salariés ils
ont pu ainsi faire changer le regard que
les entrepreneurs portait sur les
seniors anticipant la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre que le départ des baby boomer
du marché de l'emploi devrait susciter
ils ont su d'un côté attirer et
fidéliser les jeunes générations et de
l'autre retenir les seniors c'est ainsi
que la suède et la finlande ont réussi à
créer un consensus autour de
l'importance d'améliorer le bien-être au
travail et de proposer des perspectives
de développement professionnel pour les
différents âges de la vie
ce gouvernement lui le nôtre a été
incapable de s'emparer de cette question
cet article parachève donc le véritable
objectif du gouvernement assis
chez une réduction des déficit de la
branche vieillesse en maintenant les
plus faibles dans la précarité et en
transférant à l'assurance chômage ce qui
relève du droit à la retraite
une gestion aussi calamiteuse ne saurait
avoir le soutien du groupe socialiste
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame mathon poinat
merci merci monsieur le président comme
vous le savez cet article prévoit le
relèvement progressif des âges limites
des versements d indemnités destinées
aux travailleurs privés d'emploi en
d'autres termes ils se contentent de
créer des chômeurs plus âgés que ceux
que nous connaissions jusqu'à présent en
effet comme les nonces le rapport cet
article vise uniquement
je cite à mettre en cohérence les
dispositifs relatifs à l'indemnisation
des travailleurs involontairement privé
d'emploi avec les mesures de relèvement
des âges de retraite et que l'avait
l'adverbe là et quand même assez
savoureux et c'est bien là où se situe
le problème d'ailleurs cet article n'a
pour objectif que d'être une simple
mesure de coordination pour donner une
certaine cohérence à des mesures qui
prisent tout ensemble constitue votre
texte particulièrement injuste et
particulièrement idéologique
cet article et plus généralement ce
texte donc n'apporte aucune solution
pour réduire le chômage et notamment
celui des seniors
rien ou presque la seule mesure que vous
avancez n'aura malheureusement aucun
effet durable sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors en effet cette mesure qui est
d'ailleurs continue à l'article 32 et
constitue une énième exonération des
charges patronales pour les embauches de
seniors a déjà démontré son inefficacité
elle n'aura qu'un effet d'aubaine pour
les entreprises et creusera un peu plus
les déficits des comptes sociaux vous
n'explos ray aucune piste nouvelle pour
tenter de résoudre le chômage qui ne
cesse de progresser
au final avec votre texte vous faites
une double erreur puisque aucune action
concrète n'est fait pour l'emploi
aucune action concrète et équitable pour
un vrai droit à la retraite
donc cette situation paradoxale nous la
dénonçons et vous voulez maintenant des
gens dans un emploi qu'ils n'ont déjà
pas donc prévoir que les chômeurs
pourront maintenant percevoir des
indemnités de chômage jusqu'à 67 ans ne
résout rien vous créez simplement une
nouvelle catégorie de chômeurs
plus âgés c'est aussi un transfert de
charge et ce transfert de charges pose
d'ailleurs de gros problèmes aux
partenaires sociaux qu'ils ne savent pas
encore comment cette mesure va être
financé et cette question toutefois
vouloir renvoyer à plus tard
parce qu'aujourd'hui pour vous monsieur
le ministre l'important c'est avant tout
de faire adopter ce texte
peu importe les problèmes pourtant le
problème est posé
comment financer l'indemnisation des
chômeurs âgés
alors le troisième âge va quand même
entrés en force dans les agences de pôle
emploi
et ce troisième âge va pouvoir ainsi
faire connaissance avec les moins de 28
ans aux chômeurs eux aussi quelle belle
rencontre
la rapprochement entre générations pour
qu'ensemble n'est ce pas il cherche un
emploi
nous sommes donc ici dans une situation
quelque peu étrange de 16 à 67 ans tous
au chômage tous précaires et tous à pôle
emploi et comment d'ailleurs ne pas
évoquer cependant le marasme
créé par votre fusion avec l'anpe et les
assedic et les appelle tout de même
répété qu'ils commencent aujourd'hui à
devenir très sonore du personnel de pôle
emploi mais avec monsieur sarkozy
puisque tout est possible il semble que
pour ça la promesse ici sera tenu merci
chers collègues
la parole est à madame là bas
oui monsieur le président cet article
prévoit donc le relèvement progressif d
âge limite de versement des indemnités
destinées au travail aux travailleurs
privés d'emploi
en d'autres termes ils se contentent de
créer des chômeurs plus âgés que ceux
que nous connaissons jusqu'à présent en
effet les nonces le rapport cet art clic
vise uniquement à mettre en cohérence
les dispositifs relative à
l'indemnisation des travailleurs
involontairement privé d'emploi avec les
mesures de relèvement des âges de
retraite
et là c'est bien là où se situe le
problème
cet article n'a pour objectif que d'être
une simple mesure de coordination pour
donner de la cohérence à des mesures qui
prisent tout ensemble constitue notre
texte injuste et de logique
cet article et plus généralement votre
texte n'apporte aucune solution pour
réduire le chômage et notamment celui
des seniors
donc au final vous faites une double
erreur au lieu de tout faire pour que
nos concitoyens puissent d'une part
occuper un emploi au cours de leur vie
active et puissent d'autre part avoir à
l'issue de cette période un vrai droit à
la retraite vous mélangez tout vous
devriez agir pour que dû sortir de
l'école au moment de la retraite les
français trouvaient conserver un emploi
et qu'ils soient bien payés de qualité
et agir pour qu'ensuite à 60 ans il joue
il a droit à la retraite bien méritée
mais plutôt que cela vous n'agissez que
pour réduire le chômage tout en décidant
de prolonger la durée de cette vie
active en reculant l'âge de la retraite
donc prévoir que les chômeurs pourront
maintenant percevoir des indemnités de
chômage jusqu'à 67 ans ne résout rien
vous créez simplement une nouvelle
catégorie de chômeurs plus âgés c'est
simplement un transfert de charge et ce
transfert de charges pose d'ailleurs de
gros problèmes aux partenaires sociaux
qu'ils ne savent pas encore comment
cette mesure est financier mais il est
vrai que votre souci puisque vous avez
renvoyé toutes les pistes
n'est pas votre souci puisque vous avez
renvoyé toutes ces questions à plus tard
maintenant si vous nous si nous voulons
être un père nick monsieur le ministre
nous pourrions vous conseillez
d'accompagner cette mesure d'autres
beaucoup plus prosaïque concernant
l'aménagement des agences de pôle emploi
il faudra maintenant prévoir que les
agences de pôle emploi soient équipés
adapter en conséquence plus de sièges
car passé un certain âge faire la queue
debout pendant des heures est fatiguant
des bâtiments adaptés pour recevoir des
personnes âgées avec des rentes incliné
pour recevoir le chômeur se déplaçant
les gangs lot
ainsi alors que le chômage est si grave
dans notre pays vous demander à des
personnes déjà âgées de se maintenir
dans l'emploi et de se remettre s'il le
faut en chercher
mais finalement voilà le premier
objectif de votre texte vous cherchez
encourager le rapprochement des
générations comme ma collègue vous l'a
dit tout à l'heure et bien à pôle emploi
aussi les générations se donnent la main
et cherche ensemble du travail qui
n'existe pas les agents de pôle emploi
dont nous allons d'ailleurs le travail
vont devoir s'habituer à s'adresser à un
public encore plus vaste de 16 à 67 ans
tous au chômage tous précaires car à
pôle emploi se retrouvent tous les
exclus du travail tous les exclus de
votre système construit que pau que pour
quelques-uns et puis quand ces mêmes
personnes ont épuisé leurs droits chez
pôle emploi
savez-vous on les retrouve à la soupe
populaire et même dans la rue même à 67
ans nous sommes donc contre cet article
et l'ensemble de votre texte reste dans
le déni il augmente les bornes de l'âge
d'âge il augmente le nombre de
trimestres nécessaires pour partir à la
retraite
il fait tout cela sans se soucier si nos
concitoyens ont du travail
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame catherine tasca
tuer le président monsieur le ministre
avec cet article 15 le gouvernement
entend procéder progressivement
relèvement des âges limite de versement
des indemnités destinées aux
travailleurs privés d'emploi
c'est une conséquence directe du recul
des bornes d'âge de la retraite
cette disposition n'est pas que
technique elle va entraîner un transfert
de charge de la branche retraite sur les
allocations chômage notamment
comme nous le savons la croissance reste
faible
si le gouvernement table sur une hausse
de 2% l'année prochaine
nombre d'experts estiment que la
croissance ne sera pas supérieure à 1 3%
hors nous savons qu'en dessous de 2% le
potentiel de création d'emplois est
faible voire nul selon certains
commentateurs qui estime que la reprise
pourrait se faire sans que le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi baisse dans des
proportions notables
s'ajoute à cela le fait que le
gouvernement a engagé une politique
d'austérité qui elle aussi impactera le
volume des demandeurs d'emploi la
croissance n'est pas tout il est
indispensable de soutenir l'activité
économique
or le gouvernement a fait un choix
contraire en adoptant une politique
d'austérité
les dépenses de l'état vont être gelées
en valeur pendant trois ans c'est à dire
qu'elle ne suivront même pas l'inflation
prévue à un ennemi pour ça en 2011 et 1
75% en 2012 et 2013
votre logique est donc contre-productive
votre politique de rigueur va fragiliser
le nécessaire soutien dont nos
concitoyens et notre économie ont besoin
de ce fait nos chances de renouer avec
la reprise sont amoindries et la baisse
du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi est
compromise
or c'est bien l'emploi et son
développement qui sont au coeur de la
problématique
le gouvernement ne semble pas avoir pris
conscience de cet enjeu majeur et cette
disposition en est une nouvelle
illustration
comme nous l'avons vu durant la
discussion générale mais également au
cours de l'examen des articles
les personnes de plus de 55 64 ans ne
sont que 39% à être encore en situation
d'emploi dans la tranche 60 64 ans seuls
17,1 pour cent des personnes ont un
emploi soit 15 points de moins que la
moyenne européenne
à ce titre une récente parution du pôle
emploi consacrée aux perspectives
economic observer que pour la hausse du
chômage
c'est pour les demandeurs d'emploi de 50
ans ou plus que cette progression a été
la plus marquée + 7 et demi pour cent
dans ce contexte le déplacement des
bornes d'âge va donc peser sur le nombre
des seniors demandeurs d'emploi certes
vous mettez en place un certain nombre
de mesures telles que le tutorat
mais c'est bel et bien d'une
mobilisation générale pour l'emploi des
seniors dont nous avons besoin
à défaut ces mesures risquent fort de se
solder par de nouveaux échecs comme ce
fut le cas avec votre tentative
d'inciter les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés à se doter d' accord sur
l'emploi des seniors ou à définir un
plan d'action sur le sujet nous savons
tous que les effets ont été on ne peut
plus minces
l'autre dimension concerne les impacts
financiers car qu'en sera-t-il des
conséquences sur les allocations chômage
ne s'agit-il pas d'un transfert de
charges d'une branche à l'autre nous le
penser en tout cas ce que nous pensons
en outre qu'en sera-t-il aussi du nombre
des bénéficiaires du rsa et des minima
sociaux
pour ce qui est du rsa le 30 septembre
dernier annonce été faite qu'en 2011 le
gouvernement avait prévu de passer à 9
135 mille bénéficiaires
puis 1,13 million en 2012 et enfin 1,2
million en 2013
est ce que ces chiffres intègrent les
conséquences du recul des bornes d'âge
nous l'ignorons puisqu'aux dires du
ministre des solidarités actives
cette montée en charge n'a été pensé qu'
au regard d'une possible reprise
économique nous aimerions avoir votre
propre réponse monsieur le ministre
sur ce point vous l'aurez compris en
cohérence avec l'ensemble de nos prises
de position mais aussi au regard des
impacts importants et négatifs que ce
relèvement des âges limites aura sur les
allocations chômage ainsi que sur
l'ensemble des minima sociaux
nous nous opposons à l'adoption de cette
disposition et nous déposerons
un amendement de suppression merci
jacques collègue monsieur soeur à la
parole monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues dans
le prolongement de l'intervention de
catherine tasca
je voulais vous poser une question
monsieur le ministre
e certains travailleurs salaires et de
salariés sont aujourd'hui couverts par
des accords de cessation anticipée
d'activité liée à l'âge ou à la
pénibilité de leur activité
ces accords sont en cours d'application
or on m'a cité le cas de bénéficiaires
de ces accords de pré retraite qui
risquerait avec le recul des conditions
d'âge de départ en retraite de se
trouver enfin deux conventions sans
remplir les conditions d'âge pour
bénéficier de leur retraite à taux plein
alors c'est une question très concrète
monsieur le ministre
de deux choses l'une où je les aurai
relaie les informations qui m'ont été
données ne sont pas exactes et il n'y a
aucun cas où une personne en pré
retraite actuellement va se trouver à la
fin de sa pré-retraite à la convention
va donc achevé son cours sans se trouver
le halage nouveau de la retraite prévue
par le projet de loi dans ce cas là je
retire ma question va vous m'expliquerez
que ça ne se pose pas ou alors ça se
pose et si ça se pose comment réglons le
problème de ces salariés ou anciens
salariés qui sont couverts par ces
accords et qui vont se retrouver à la
fin de la période couverte par l'accord
sans remplir les conditions nouvelles
d'âge pour toucher leur retraite à temps
plein c'est une question extrêmement
concrètes mais je pense qu'elles
concernent
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens tu
as collègue monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
d'abord sur le jeu je vais devenir votre
question je suis le sénateur sur d'abord
il n'y a pas moins idéologique que notre
réforme j'entends plusieurs fois sur les
bancs notamment- du groupe src bien mais
c'est une forme de logique ya pas moins
idéologique que d'un très fort pour dire
on bouge l'âge parce que je les ai déjà
dit à plusieurs reprises c'était quand
même le bon sens dans le domaine une
réforme des retraites
et puis il ya d'autres éléments et puis
en même temps on dit ah oui il ya des
gens qui font partie d'une population
particulière qui ne peuvent pas parce
qu'ils ont commencé tôt cetera ou la
pénibilité et donc est ce moment là il
ya des cas particuliers évidemment
qu'ils sont traités il ya pas moins
idéologique il ya un message si vous les
danseux dans ce domaine qui est moins
très éloigné de ce que pense le
gouvernement
et quand vous dites si contre l'emploi
des jeunes au fond prolonger l'âge de la
retraite et des gens qui vont rester au
travail donc c'est contre l'emploi déjà
ça voudrait dire tout simplement que
entre guillemets les vieux prés de
l'emploi des jeunes
c'est pas comme ça que fonctionne la
société française c'est vraiment
épouvantable
d'ailleurs comme manière de devoir ou de
dire mais lors de demander aux gens de
partir à 40 ans enfin tout ça est
épouvantable et les vieux entre
guillemets ils ont aussi leur place dans
l'entreprise
ils ont aussi leur place heureusement
ils ont aussi leur place dans la vie
dans la vie professionnelle est
d'ailleurs souvent aidés même au sénat
josé parent mais je n'osais pas non josé
pas mais là c'est donc heureusement
qu'ils ont leur place j'imagine que
d'ailleurs vous le pensez aussi
évidemment qu'ils ont leur place on
jette pas comme ça des gens à 55 en
disant ça y est c'est fini ta vie
professionnelle et tu rends dans des
dispositifs sociaux compliqué avant de
ponte avec la retraite enfin écouter le
mieux c'est quand même société qui fasse
travailler tout le monde qui fasse
travailler les les personnes plus
expérimentées qui transfère et
transmettre leur expérience selon des
conditions particulières
dont on aménage les fins de carrière je
suis d'accord évidemment faut aménager
les fins de carrière
on travaille pas de la même manière à 60
ans a fortiori à 62 ans cac 40 ans
évidemment il faut aménager les fins de
carrière
mais enfin les jeunes ont évidemment
aussi leur place total dans le monde du
travail est le plus vite possible mais
c'est pas parce qu'il ya une personne
seniors qui restent dans un emploi que
tout d'un coup ça va automatiquement
créé un emploi pour les jeunes
d'ailleurs sinon on aurait le taux
d'emploi des jeunes probablement plus
élevé d'europe
puisqu'on a un faible taux d'emploi des
seniors c'est pas le cas donc le marché
du travail ne se construit pas comme ça
donc les vieux entre guillemets les
vieux salariés les salariés seniors ne
sont pas l'ennemi du travail des jeunes
certainement pas et vous ne pouvez pas
comme ça opposé les catégories d'âge si
vous opposer les générations en disant
c'est parce qu'il ne parte pas à la
retraite que nos jeunes trouveront pas
un emploi c'est là vous commencez à
faire de la stigmatisation d'une
catégorie d'âge d'une opposition entre
les générations et je crois que c'est
pas bon la seule la seule façon de
développer le marché du travail c'est la
croissance seule façon c'est de ces la
création de richesse qui amène no no no
no no salariés à travailler plus
longtemps tout simplement parce que la
création de richesse la croissance fait
que le marché du travail se développe et
puis c'est aussi la fluidité de ce
marché du travail la capacité à
s'adapter c'est la formation c'est tout
cela c'est tout cet environnement du
marché du travail s'est pas uniquement
la retraite évidemment qui peut répondre
au marché du travail c'est pas la
retraite n'est pas la réponse aux
marchés du du travail donc je voulais
quand même leur dire aussi que c'est
vrai que l'unedic va probablement avoir
des charges supplémentaires
vous l'avez dit oui l'unedic va sûrement
avoir des charges supplémentaires
elle va aussi avoir des recettes
supplémentaires il va avoir des charges
parce que des personnes qui vont rester
dans les dispositifs de chômage parce
qu'ils n'auront pas d'emploi
c'est la réalité vous avez raison et en
même temps il ya des personnes qui vont
rester dans l'emploi et donc ils vont
continuer à cotiser
donc on aura les deux l'unedic estime
que le coût net est de 400 millions
d'euros à peu près pour nous on
considère que cette on considère quand
même que cette cette évaluation est une
évaluation extrêmement pessimiste parce
qu'elle est fondée sur des taux d'emploi
des seniors extrêmement
faible ils disent l'impact en fait de
lait des retraites c'est très faible sur
l'emploi des seniors la croissance sur
un très fin tout est très faible et donc
tout ça est très prudent dans une vision
prudente tant mieux on prend une vision
prudente il vaut mieux être prudent les
voir de bonnes surprises
enfin on mais d'un côté 400 millions
éventuellement dépenses supplémentaires
dans l'unedic pour à peu près 20
milliards de recettes supplémentaires
dans les comptes de l'assurance
vieillesse donc 400 millions contre 20
milliards ça reste sur le plan de
l'argent public
quelque chose de évidemment très très
positif mais en plus nous on a demandé à
l'adresse de faire une étude plus fine
de l'impact de la réforme des retraites
sur l'emploi des seniors alors je vous
ordonne le résultat entre 55 et 59 ans
c'est plus 9,9 points c'est grosso modo
10 points on est aujourd'hui entre 55 et
59 ans à un taux d'emploi de 58 et demi
58% et demi de cette catégorie d'âge et
dans l'emploi
on pense que donc ça va augmenter de 10
points est passé à 68 et demi pour les
60 à 64 le taux d'emploi est évidemment
par principe beaucoup plus faible il est
de 17,2 mémoire de 17% et on pense qu'il
va augmenter de 10 et demi pour cent
donc il passerait à 27 et demi pour cent
en 2000 en 2018 chez moi c'est les
chiffres de la drees après on peut
discuter mais moi je pense que ça a
évidemment un impact très fort sur
l'emploi des seniors comme le relèvement
de l'âge de la retraite a eu un impact
très fort sur l'emploi des seniors en
allemagne par exemple et on n'a aucune
raison d'être moins bon que les
allemands dans le domaine de l'emploi
des seniors
voilà ce que je souhaitais vous dire
monsieur le sénateur sur les la plupart
des conventions qui sont signés avec des
consultations pré retraite au fond ils
sont signés avec les entreprises vise
l'âge légal ne donne pas l'âge exact 10
vise l'âge légal donc par principe l'âge
légal se déplaçant la convention veau et
ça c'est toutes les conventions dont on
a connaissance n'a pas connaissance de
toutes les conventions c'est des
conventions de droit privé toutes ces
conventions sont en général fixé sur
l'âge légal sans préciser
le 60 précise l'âge légal est donc cet
âge légal par précipite bouge donc ça
cesse
à ce jeu s'adapte en fait si certaines
conventions visées à ce moment là
uniquement un âge précis
nous on va demander on est en train de
faire une enquête en fait dans les
différentes régions pour bien essayé de
recenser cela évidemment on y
apporterait une réponse merci de ce
ministre alors nous avons trois
amendements identiques qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune l'amendement
il est présenté par adam qui arrive
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet article qui prévoit
le relèvement progressif d âge limite de
versement des indemnités destinées aux
travailleurs privés d'emploi est une
aberration supplémentaires il est la
conséquence directe de l'article 6 vous
allez prolonger un peu plus le désarroi
et l'humiliation d'un grand nombre de
nos concitoyens
seulement 38% des 55-64 ans sont actifs
être au chômage ce n'est pas un choix
être au chômage c'est déstabilisant
lorsque l'on a travaillé toute une vie
et que l'on se retrouve à 55 ans 56 ans
sans emploi on développe un sentiment
d'inutilité et de rejet que vous allez
amplifier la précarité économique
entraîne l'essor de l'avs une
vulnérabilité sociale votre projet et je
regrette de vous le dire vraiment un
projet de classe les plus démunis les
plus vulnérables sont les premiers
touchés
votre projet est un amplificateur de la
précarité
il ajoute de l'injustice à l'injustice
vous nous parler d'avenir messieurs les
ministres mais que proposez-vous aux 62
% des plus de 55 ans qui se retrouvent
au chômage
parce que les employeurs considèrent
qu'ils sont trop vieux ils ne
travailleront pas plus longtemps mais
ils vont galérer deux années de plus la
majorité des entreprises n'est pas prête
à embaucher des employés de plus de 50
ans et vous le savez
elle les voit comme un frein à la
croissance et le fait qu'on repousse
l'âge de la retraite ne le fera pas ne
les fera pas changer d'avis alors vous
les sacrifier une fois de plus ils sont
3 fois victime de la crise de votre
politique économique et de votre
politique sociale
de plus les coûts économiser sur les
pensions de retraite sont
automatiquement vont automatiquement
transférés vers l'assurance l'assurance
chômage et le rsa 440 à 530 millions
d'euros par an c'est le coût corps à la
réforme des retraites pour l'assurance
chômage
mécaniquement la durée de prise en
charge par l'assurance chômage
des demandeurs d'emploi de plus de 60
ans va s'allonger
ce qui ne sera pas versée par les
régimes de retraite
le sera par l'assurance chômage ou les
départements tout cela va peser encore
sur les finances de nos collectivités
locales déjà mise à mal
il est vrai que vous êtes coutumier des
transferts de charges sans transfert des
moyens adéquats
c'est une habitude faire payer par les
autres ce que vous n'avez plus vous ne
pouvait plus assumer mes collègues
conseillers généraux et présidents de
conseils généraux savent de quoi ils
parlent à travers de quoi je parle à
travers la suppression de cet amendement
nous ne voulons pas interrompre le
versement des indemnités chômage à 65
ans nous voulons nous opposer une fois
de plus au recul du taux plein à 67 ans
et à ses conséquences qui je le redis
une fois de plus sont inacceptables et
qui touche en premier les plus précaires
d'entre nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous présentons cet amendement
de suppression de l'article 15
merci chers collègues l'amendement 256
il est présenté par madame blondin il y
avait là comment est abordé la question
du chômage au travers de ce projet de
loi les chômeurs resteront au chômage
deux en plus notre société issue des
trente glorieuses à temps sacraliser la
valeur emplois que ceux qui en sont
exclus sont non seulement difficultés
financières mais aussi en souffrance par
le regard que l'on porte sur eux à l'âge
qu'ils ont ou même
qu'ils portent sur eux mêmes au moment
où le demandeur d'emploi âgé allait
entrer dans une période de retraite de
reconnaissance des efforts passés et
bien vous le condamner à deux ans de
plus de mal vivre la france compte plus
de 5 millions d'hommes et de femmes
touchées par le chômage
franchement c'est votre mission on
aurait pu expérience politique de
l'emploi plus ambitieuse le total des
cinq catégories de pôle emploi atteint
en 2010 les 4,4 millions de personnes en
métropole
270 mille chômeurs outre-mer 324000
dispensés de recherche d'emploi et bien
sûr des milliers de jeunes en situation
de galère qui ne sont pas dans les
statistiques
votre devoir c'est de stopper
l'hémorragie s'est aussi de protéger les
chômeurs et précaires et cet article ne
fait qu'aggraver la situation de tous
compte tenu du faible taux d'emploi le
recul de l'âge de départ rendra encore
plus difficiles
une carrière complète de moins en moins
de nos concitoyens pourront prétendre
donc au taux plein sans compter que ces
mesures sont financièrement inefficace
vous ne faites que transférer les coûts
de l'assurance vieillesse sur
l'assurance chômage
raymonde le texier disait vous remplacez
les jeunes retraités par de vieux
chômeurs vous remplacez des gens
soulagés par des gens galèrent et pour
les chômeurs en fin de droits eh ben ce
sera éventuellement aux associations ou
aux conseils généraux de verser
davantage de revenu de solidarité active
les transferts de charge quelle belle
mesures d'économies surtout quand la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
met en péril la majorité des
collectivités comme vos amis du medef
qui privatise les bénéfices et
externalise les coûts de requalification
de leur site
vous construisez un système de retraite
qui transfère les déséquilibres aux
autres
l'unedic a du souci à se faire vous avez
cité les chiffres on peut les étaler
dans le temps le surcoût pourra
atteindre 230 millions d'euros en 2015
480 en 2016 530 en 2018
à moins bien sûr d'une amélioration de
l'emploi des seniors qui limiterait la
casse mais nous arriverions quand même à
440 millions nous sommes très loin d'une
politique responsable et ambitieuse une
politique active de l'emploi reposerait
sur la conversion de l'économie
conversion écologique relocalisation
partage du temps de travail dans un
contexte réel de décroissance sélective
solidaire équitable mais alors cela ça
vous est tellement idéologiquement
insupportable que vous continuez à
pédaler sur le vélo de la croissance
sans vous rendre compte que votre chaîne
à des rails
c'est pourquoi chers collègues je vous
invitais supprimer cet article qui ne
fait qu aggraver la précarité des
seniors mais si chers collègues le 346
rectifié tombant monsieur rapporteur
l'avis de la commission
ces deux amendements donc veulent
supprimer l'article 15 qui permet de
relever
les âges permettant de conserver un
revenu de remplacement au titre du
chômage
si on les adopte et bien sûr certains
chômeurs perdraient leur revenu de
remplacement sans avoir le droit de
liquider leur pension de retraite
donc c'est un article un dispensaire et
vous le savez par ailleurs la comme les
affaires sociales a complété le projet
de loi pour permettre aux bénéficiaires
de l'allocation équivalent retraite
l'avers de la conserver jusqu'à ce
qu'ils atteignent l'âge qui permet
d'éditer leur part sur dans le cabinet
favorable merci monsieur le ministre
même avis défavorable pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter le 149 veuille bien
levé la main merci que ceux qui sont
contre veille bien levé la main il n'est
pas adoptée sur le 256 même vote
nous votons sur l'article 15 demandes
d'explications de vote
s'il n'y en a pas que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veuille bien levé la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuille bien levé la main il est adopté
nous arrivons chapitre iii sur la limite
d'âge et de durée de service des
militaires sur cet article
nous avons une demande de parole de
madame gonthier maurin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
16 porte sur le relèvement de deux
années des limites d'âge des militaires
et des durées de service des militaires
sous contrat en apparence cette
disposition pourrait sembler équitable
et de bon sens en effet comme tous les
français comme tous les salariés comme
tous les fonctionnaires
bien que ce qu'ali qualificative
conviennent mal à ces hommes et ces
femmes
il pourrait paraître normal qu'il soit
eux aussi appelés à fournir un effort
pour assurer la pérennité de notre
système de retraites pourtant cette
argumentation ne tient compte ni de la
réalité ni de la spécificité de l'êta
militaire
il faudra tout d'abord rappelé que les
militaires ont déjà fourni cet effort
avec la modification de leur dispositif
statutaire en 2005 la loi du 24 mars
2005 portant statut génère
des militaires avaient ainsi déjà
reculer les limites d'âge d'un à cinq
ans pour les officiers et d'un à trois
ans pour les sous-officiers
ceci a d'ailleurs été critiqué par le
haut comité d'évaluation de la condition
militaire dans la vie qu'il a rendue sur
le projet de loi qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui
il estimait en effet et je cite cette
mesure serait à tout le moins prématuré
les effets combinés de la loi sur les
retraites de 2003 et du relèvement des
limites d'âge opéré par le statut
général des dames des militaires de 2005
n'étant pas encore définitif en
citations remettre aujourd'hui en cause
ce dispositif statutaire sans
concertation au travers d'un autre
projet de loi me paraît peu convenable
et surtout désinvolte à l'égard de nos
armées un projet de loi qui considère
après tout comme vous le faite que les
militaires sont des fonctionnaires comme
les autres qui ne reconnaît ni la
spécificité de leur condition ni leurs
mérites risque d'être très mal ressenti
dans l'institution en second lieu
ce relèvement de deux ans entre en
totale contradiction avec la nécessité
d'avoir des armées jeunes principale
garantie de leurs qualités
opérationnelles
le hce cm avait également relevé que
cette mesure je re site était de nature
à conduire un vieillissement trop
important de l'ensemble des effectifs
surtout si elle était accompagnée d'un
allongement de la durée des services
ouvrant droit à la liquidation immédiate
de la pension de retraite fin de
citation troisième le cette mesure est
aussi contradictoire avec le type de
déroulement de carrière qui a toujours
essayé tu as toujours essayé d'appliquer
le ministère de la défense
il consiste à ce que les limites d'âge
reste suffisamment basses notamment dans
les unités opérationnelles afin de
stimuler les grades et d'un niveau
subalterne et d'éviter un vieillissement
trop importants dans les grades les plus
élevés
enfin cette mesure posera inévitablement
des problèmes de qualité de recrutement
celle ci a déjà été largement éprouvée
avec la suspension de la conscription
qui représente un vivier très important
de talent d'yves
quel attrait peuvent encore aujourd'hui
représenter nos armées auprès de jeunes
sinon plus par exemple la possibilité
d'une bonne reconversion professionnelle
au bout de 15 ans d'années de service
non décidément ces mesures ne relève de
relèvement des limites d'âge et de durée
de service qui pourrait sembler banal et
logique auront de graves conséquences
sur le moral et sur l'organisation même
de nos armées les mais les militaires
font en effet un métier exigeant qui
peut aller parfois je vous le rappelle
jusqu'au sacrifice de leur vie
un métier qui demande un engagement de
tous les instants
ils ont largement contribué à l'effort
imposé par la rgpp notamment en matière
de réductions budgétaires et de
diminution des effectifs
monsieur le ministre ne leur imposez pas
ces mesures qui comme pour le reste de
nos concitoyens sont injustes et
inefficaces
merci chers collègues la parole est un
monsieur qui fait merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres
jacques collègues il nous semble que le
sujet de cet article 16 à savoir la
limite d'âge et de durée de service des
militaires auraient dû faire l'objet
d'un examen approfondi en commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées du sénat
nous aurions pu alors apporté quelques
lumières au texte du gouvernement et
ainsi lui permettre de l'améliorer ou en
tout cas de ne pas commettre des erreurs
c'est d'ailleurs dans cet état d'esprit
positif que nous avons déposé nos
amendements sur cet article 16 et c'est
aussi sans doute cet état d'esprit qui
anime et monsieur le président de roi
quand il a déposé un amendement à
l'article 20 destiné à maintenir le
bénéfice de la bonification du 5e à 15
ans de service j'espère que d'ailleurs
que le gouvernement réservera à
l'amendement du président de rouen un
autre sort que celui qu'il réserve aux
nôtres c'est à dire en règle générale le
rejet pur et simple avec la
professionnalisation des armées
le recrutement du personnel militaire
est confronté à une concurrence
permanente sur le marché de l'emploi
les armées doivent attirer désormais une
ressource jeunes vers un métier
caractérisée notamment par des
suggestions que ne connaît pas le
secteur civil comme la disponibilité des
opérations extérieures les risques
particuliers à la fonction militaire et
les mesures proposées par votre projet
viennent compliquer encore cette
situation les pensions des militaires
sont en effet régie au même titre que
celles attribuées aux fonctionnaires
civils par le code des pensions civiles
et militaires
toutefois les pensions militaires
présente plusieurs particularités du
fait de la spécificité du métier et des
carrières militaires
d'une part elles prennent en compte à
travers les modalités du calcul des
annuités
les conditions particulières d'exercice
du métier militaire et d'autre part elle
permet d'assurer la maîtrise des flux
qui caractérise la gestion du personnel
militaire à ce titre elles remplissent
donc une double fonction elle constitue
un instrument de gestion concourant avec
d'autres à la jeunesse et aux pyramides
âge des effectifs militaires
elles revêtent alors le caractère d'une
pension de reconversion
nous soutenons et vous aurez du mal à
nous démontrer le contraire que votre
réforme met à mal cette double fonction
d'une part parce qu'elle vient percuter
de plein fouet la difficile et complexe
et périlleuse manoeuvre des ressources
humaines engagés par les armes et par la
rgpp et d'autre part parce que vous
allez trouble et profondément le
fonctionnement interne des armées en
asséchant l'attractivité de la fonction
militaire
pourtant monsieur le ministre nous
sommes convaincus que la question d'une
évolution de la durée des services
ouvrant droit à liquidation de la
pension des militaires méritent d'être
étudiées selon deux points de vue ses
conséquences sur la carrière et la
condition des intéressés d'une part son
impact sur les capacités et des besoins
opérationnels des armées d'autre part
ce que vous pourriez nous communiquer
monsieur le ministre une étude d'impact
analysant les conséquences de votre
projet de loi sur les carrières
militaires sur les effectifs des forces
et in fine et sur la tenue du contrat
opérationnel
pourriez-vous nous dire aussi monsieur
le ministre comment préserver la
cohésion du système tome des armes est
pris en tenaille entre la déflation dieu
a l'air gpp et l'évolution des retraites
militaires induite par votre projet de
loi il est évident que la communauté
militaire doit contribuer comme tout le
monde pourrait-on dire à l'effort
collectif national de financement des
régimes de retraite ni plus ni moins
sauf que le haut comité d'évaluation de
la condition militaire avait rédigé son
quatrième rapport en janvier 2010 qu'il
avait alors remis au gouvernement et au
chef de l'état
nous regrettons profondément que toutes
les recommandations avancées par ce haut
comité est été ignoré par votre
gouvernement et c'est pourquoi monsieur
le ministre les mesures que vous
proposez auront des conséquences sur le
périmètre et le profil des armées que
nous pensons être mal mesuré dans ce
projet doit merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur dassault non
monsieur
non
très bien alors nous passons n'y a pas
d'autres demandes de parole j'ai trois
amendements identiques qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune
le premier l'amendement 21 il est
présenté par monsieur autain président
le sionisme est cher collègue à
l'occasion de notre intervention sur
l'article 9 et des amendements que nous
avons défendues à cette occasion nous
sommes longuement revenu sur le cas
particulier de la retraite des
militaires
regrettant au passage que le ministre de
la défense nationale se soient montrés
incapables de tenir les engagements
qu'il avait pris devant les militaires
étant fermement opposé à toute
augmentation des bornes d'âge pour
financer votre contre-réforme des
retraites
nous sommes opposés à cet article 16 qui
vise à relever de deux années l'ensemble
des limites d'âge des militaires
actuellement fixée entre 45 et 64 ans
toutefois je voudrais souligner le fait
que pour ne pas gêner le déroulement des
carrières des officiers appelé à devenir
prochainement officiers généraux le
gouvernement a opté pour un autre mode
de relèvement
car comme le souligne notre à porter je
cite le relèvement ne s'effectuera pas
nécessairement à raison de quatre mois
par génération pour tous les militaires
même si tous atteindront les nouvelles
limites d'âge à la date prévue fin de
citation démonstration est ainsi fait
que contrairement au discours tenu
depuis le début de nos travaux dans cet
hémicycle
d'autres prix d'autres pistes pouvaient
être envisagées notamment afin de rendre
cette réforme moins insupportable pour
nos concitoyens mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir dans la suite des
débats aussi par cohérence avec
l'ensemble des amendements que
défendons sur ce projet de loi est parce
que nous sommes convaincus qu'il demeure
injuste est insuffisant comme nous
l'avons dit à maintes reprises pour
financer l'avenir des régimes de
retraite
nous proposons par cet amendement
la suppression de cet article merci
chers collègues l'amendement 151
il est présenté par monsieur godefroy
président monsieur le ministre
l'article 16 prévoit le relèvement de
deux années des limites d'âge des
militaires ainsi que le relèvement des
durées de service des militaires sous
contrat je me suis procuré le rapport
2010 du haut comité d'évaluation de la
condition militaire
d'après ce rapport les militaires
prennent en moyenne leur retraite
à 43 ans 8 mois cet âge varie selon le
grade 51 ans et trois mois pour les
officiers 45 ans et 8 mois pour les
sous-officiers 32 ans et deux mois pour
les militaires du rang
en moyenne les personnels militaires
partent après une durée de service de 23
ans et 8 mois et bénéficie toujours en
moyenne d'une bonification de huit ans
et quatre mois opérations extérieures
services aériens
un domaine que je connais
particulièrement bien les sous marins
soit totale durée moyenne d'assurance de
32 ans et deux mois
à titre de comparaison les
fonctionnaires civils de l'état prennent
leur retraite à 58 ans et huit mois
après trente trois années six années six
mois de service
les pensions des militaires sont
relativement faibles 1484 euros fin 2008
contre contre 1957 euros pour les
fonctionnaires civils
il faut également rappeler que les deux
tiers 63% des militaires quittent
service sans droits à pension militaire
de retraite
c'est le cas de la quasi-totalité des
militaires durant 92 % et du quart des
sous-officiers puisqu'ils sont rayé des
cadres avant d'avoir accompli 15 années
de service
les militaires français partent à la
retraite plus jeunes que les autres
actifs mais un peu plus âgés monsieur le
ministre que les militaires américains
britanniques ou allemands c'est le
rapport qui le constate il ne s' il ne
s'agit donc pas d'un avantage nationale
mais bien une spécificité de l'êta
militaire que l'on retrouve dans les
autres pays
quant à la proposition de l'article 16
le rapport énonce loi
sur blanc qu'il n'est pas souhaitable de
relever la limite d'âge des militaires
en effet il énonce qu'une telle réforme
serait de nature à conduire un
vieillissement trop important de
l'ensemble des effectifs un relèvement
des limites d'âge pourtant sur les
grades terminaux de l'ensemble des corps
risquerait de déséquilibrer la gestion
et de ralentir des carrières ce qui
serait contraire à l'évolution induite
par les nouveaux statuts particuliers
par ailleurs elle nécessiterait de
mettre en place un management
particulier les fans carrière la
problématique de l'allongement de vie
active des militaires posait difficulté
la conjonction des facteurs structurels
induits par cette réforme et de facteurs
conjoncturels tels que la disparition le
transfert de régiments va aboutir à une
impossibilité totale de reclasser
certains personnels les collectivités
locales sont déjà sollicités
une fois de plus l'état qui les poussent
à reprendre des personnels dont il veut
plus organiser un transfert de ses
charges à leurs dépens en jeu par des
collectivités locales aussi en cohérence
avec l'ensemble des propos que nous
avons tenues depuis le début de l'examen
de ce texte
nous vous proposons cette disposition de
suppression de l'article
merci chers collègues de 347 rectifié
tombe
monsieur le rapporteur quel est l'avis
de la commission donc les amendements 21
et 151 folle de supprimer donc l'article
16 qui relève les limites d'âge et les
durées de service des militaires et on
ne voit pas de raisons objectives
d'écarter purement et simplement les
militaires du projet de réforme avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement merci monsieur le président
je voudrais remercier deux orateurs qui
ont défendu les amendements et qui ont
dit des choses qui sont précises et en
particulier issus du dernier rapport je
voudrais si vous me voulez bien monsieur
le froid les relativiser un tout petit
peu en disant d'une part comme le dit
très justement le rapporteur est ce la
raison pour laquelle je le suis pour
dire que c'est défavorable de fois mais
précisé évidemment qui a pas de raison
objective on peut pas être d'accord
principe mais de déroger au principe
même de la loi
j'aimerais vous dire sur les deux-trois
choses premièrement ce cet impact si
vous voulez de la mesure de relèvement
de va concerner que 2% des effectifs
militaires totaux dans la mesure où les
deux tiers des militaires
réalise une durée de service qui est
bien plus faible que 15 ans et en
moyenne vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur le militaire durant une durée
moyenne de carrière de quatre à cinq ans
et c'était 2,9 en 2012 donc ça va en
diminuant
d'autre part le tiers restant à une
moyenne qui est de 22 ans de carrière le
relèvement vous le savez sera de fait
très progressif puisqu'il va s'opérer en
six ans auteur de quatre mois par an
donc compte tenu de ce relèvement très
progressif et du faible impact que cela
va avoir puisque ça m'a touché que 2 à
3% consommant des effectifs on considère
que toutes les questions que vous avez
soulevé au sujet du format des armées de
leur capacité à pouvoir remplir leur
mission tout cela trouve une réponse
c'est une réponse qu'on peut considérer
comme très mesuré je vous en dernier
lieu vous dire qu'on maintient par
ailleurs tous les avantages du régime
des militaires et j'aurai l'occasion de
le rappeler tout à l'heure c'est vrai
pour le droit à pension en jouissance
immédiate c'est vrai et sans condition
d'âge c'est vrai également pour la
décote courte qui comme vous le savez
est de dix trimestres pour les
militaires la place de vin et qui
aboutissent comme vous l'avez très
justement relevé d'ailleurs et l'un et
l'autre à ce qu'un militaire puisse
disposer d'une pension qu'ils soient des
33 ans avec un engagement qui est à 18
ans demain ça sera relevé l'âge de 35
ans vous voyez qu'on est très loin des
limites d'âge donc je le redis les
arguments vous avez débloqué étaient de
vraies questions mais je pense que je
vous apporte également de vraies
réponses
merci messieurs les explications de vote
monsieur fisher oui je viens d'entendre
monsieur le ministre
alors bien sûr dans notre logique vous
comprendrez que nous opposons pour les
militaires
car on n'oublie pas que sont des
fonctionnaires comme pour les autres
professions à ce recul d'âge de l'âge
limite d'exercice alors dans les faits
de cumuler avec l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation un cycle recul de
l'ouverture de la retraite sans décote
il prend toute sa signification ainsi le
recul d'une limite d'âge ne peut être
considéré comme un droit nouveau pour
des militaires qui souhaiteraient par
passion ou amour du métier ce consacrer
quelques années de plus à une profession
qui les épanouit associé aux autres
mesures de cette réforme
le recul de la limite h et surtout un
maintien en activité par nécessité
financière pour obtenir des pensions aux
montants le moins symbolique possible
car contrairement aux idées reçues
si le départ en retraite est accordée
plus tôt le montant des pensions reste
quand même très faible les militaires
connaissent actuellement un âge limite
de départ à la retraite entre 47 et 64
ans en raison bien sûr des nombreuses
spécificités et difficultés propres au
métier la pénibilité d'une carrière de
militaire professionnel est en effet
réel est actuellement reconnu à juste
titre par cette limite d'âge et c'est
vrai que lorsqu'ils sont engagés sur des
fronts et bien cela est inhérent à la
profession même de ces militaires de
carrière donc envoyer de longs mois en
mission loin de leur famille en caserne
est en mission à l'étranger concentrons
de très nombreuses heures de service par
jour et par semaine dans des conditions
psychologiques et physiques
particulièrement éprouvante
donc c'est une réalité alors car un
quand un militaire est envoyé sur un
lieu de conflit le temps passé en
service et de 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7
évident alors en matière de soi disant
privilèges qui sont avancés pour mieux
dégradé le droit à la retraite tous les
fonctionnaires des régimes spéciaux ont
fait mieux et ce métier à risques exige
de toute manière le maintien d'effectifs
jeunes il est également normal comme le
prévoit la loi actuelle que ceux ci
puissent bénéficier du minimum
contributif après 17 ans de service
hors la loi en plus du recul de la
limite d'âge prévoit le report du
minimum contributif pour les militaires
après 19 années et demi de service
rappelons à ce titre que le minimum
contributif est inférieur au seuil de
pauvreté
et qu'un départ au bout de dix sept ou
dix neuf et demi année ne serait se
justifier autrement que par la
difficulté du métier alors de plus il ne
faut pas oublier comme l'indiquent le
dernier rapport du haut comité
d'évaluation de la condition militaire
que six militaires français partent à la
retraite plus jeunes que les autres
actifs
ils partent cependant plus âgés que les
militaires américains britanniques ou
encore allemands bon c'est ce qui nous a
permis après les nombreuses recherches
que nous avons pu faire d'affirmer cette
spécificité militaire reconnue
internationalement et c'est pour cela
que nous souhaitions déposé cet
amendement de suppression
merci chers collègues à d'autres
demandes d'explications de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement 21
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veut bien levé la main
il n'est pas adoptée sur le 151 même
vote même vote
deux amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 794 il est
présenté par alain période
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet
amendement propose de supprimer le
premier alinéa de cet article 16 chacun
aura compris il s'agit pour nous de
rappeler notre opposition à cet article
au delà même à l'ensemble de ce projet
de loi
en décidant de bouger les trois curseurs
fondamentaux que ceux de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite celui permettant de
bénéficier d'une retraite sans décote et
en augmentant la durée de cotisation
vous imposer à nos concitoyens une
réforme qui est la plus lourde d'europe
et qui aura pour conséquence de rendre
le régime de retraite français
la plus contraignant le plus
contraignant que partout ailleurs en
europe
en effet comme le souligne à raison
thierry pech et laurent jeanneau dans le
numéro d'alternatives économiques de
juillet et août 2003 je cite la plupart
des pays qui ont décidé de relever les
seuils d'âge compense durcissement par
des durées de cotisation un fait
hier et de prendre les exemples suivants
je cite encore le royaume nine exige
désormais que trente ans de cotisations
contre 44 précédemment l'espagne se
contente de 15 ans de cotisation minimum
est de 35 ans pour une cote une pension
complète et les pays bas demandent quant
à eux 50 ans de résidence dans le pays
autrement dit est depuis en fin de
citation donc contrairement à ce que
vous ne cessez de répéter cette réforme
tend plus à faire satisfaire les agences
de notation et celles et ceux qui
recherchent une harmonisation européenne
par le bas plutôt que de prendre les
mesures nécessaires permettant de
garantir l'avenir des régimes de
retraite et leur niveau
je voudrais d'ailleurs regretté que la
commission des affaires sociales est
déclarée irrecevable
l'amendement que notre groupe avait
déposé et qui précisait qu aucune
pension ne devait être inférieur au
minimum au seuil de pauvreté
en effet à quoi serait à quoi bon serait
utile une réforme si elle n'avait pas
pour objectif premier de garantir aux
retraités actuels et à ceux qui le
deviendront une retraite supérieure au
seuil de pauvreté
à quoi bon servirait une réforme des
retraites si elle n'avait pas d'abord
comme objectif la réduction des
inégalités et l'assurance pour les
retraites des retraités de vivre
dignement
disant cela je voudrais une nouvelle
fois attiré l'attention de notre
rapporteur qui a personnellement
contribué à la réécriture de l'article
1er à que nous avons déjà examiné en
effet il prévoit un niveau de retraite
satisfaisant sans que celui ci ne soit
jamais défini sans qu'un plancher ne
soient instaurés
or pour être efficace il est nécessaire
de définir par la loi le montant dessous
duquel le niveau des pensions ne serait
plus satisfaisant aussi je voudrais
profiter de la défense de cet amendement
pour interroger leur apporterait le
gouvernement sur le montant en dessous
duquel il estime qu'une pension
n'atteint plus un niveau satisfaisant
merci monsieur le président
merci chers collègues la manne en 1218
il est présenté par monsieur rapporteur
oui monsieur le président donc c'est
juste un amendements rédactionnels ou
dans l'alinéa la troisième ligne
on remplace antérieure au pluriel part
dans sa version antérieure voilà est
votre avis donc sur le 794 de la
commission sur l'amendement 794 donc
avis défavorable de la commission
voilà si monsieur le ministre la vie sur
les deux amendements défavorable pour le
794 est favorable pour 1218 merci
monsieur ministre sur le 794 pas
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent l'adopter veuille bien levé
la main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veille bien levé la main il n'est pas
adopté un amendement 1218 pas
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter veut bien levé la
main 1218
merci que ceux qui sont contre veut bien
levé la main il est adopté
nous passons à l'amendement 796 il est
présenté par monsieur verra
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement se propose de supprimer le
deuxième alinéa de cet article qui porte
l'âge de départ à la retraite sans
décote
à 47 ans pour les militaires quand celui
ci était jusqu alors fixé à 45 ans vous
le savez nous sommes opposés sur le fond
à la logique même des mesures d'âge
puisque nous sommes convaincus que cette
disposition est destiné à contourner la
question des financements
il aurait pourtant fallu travailler plus
en amont cette question afin d'éviter
que les salariés les fonctionnaires y
compris les militaires ne paient les
prix de cette mesure
selon le dernier rapport du haut comité
d'évaluation de la condition militaire
les militaires prennent en moyenne leur
retraite à 43,8 en et partent après une
durée de service de 23,8 années et
bénéficie toujours en moyenne d'une
bonification de 8,4 en comme la
bonification donc accordé au titre des
opérations extérieures des services
aériens est sous marinier soit au total
donc une durée de cotisation
correspondant à 30 2,2 années et de
manière globale les pensions sont
relativement faibles elles sont autour
de 1484 euros pour l'année 2008
c'est pourquoi chers collègues afin
d'éviter que les militaires de carrière
notamment les sous-officiers ne soit
sanctionné nous proposons la suppression
de cet alinéa merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission sur
ce 796 796 donc encore supprimé l'alinéa
2 cette fois ci donc défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre même avis du
gouvernement pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter cet amendement 796,2
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté un amendement 795
madame assassi
merci monsieur le président selon le
dernier rapport du haut comité
d'évaluation de la condition militaire
les militaires prennent en moyenne leur
retraite à 44 ans cet âge varie bien
évidemment selon le grade 51 ans pour
les officiers 46 pour les sous-officiers
32 pour les militaires du rang
en moyenne les personnels militaires
partent après une durée de service de
23,8 années et bénéficie toujours en
moyenne d'une bonification de 8,4 au peg
services aériens sous marin soit un
total c'est-à-dire la durée moyenne
d'assurance de 32,2 ans à titre de
comparaison les fonctionnaires civils de
l'état prennent leur retraite à 59 ans
après 33 6 années soit plus 1,6 de
bonification de service toutefois à
l'issue de leur année de service les
militaires touchent des pensions
relativement faible 1484 euros contre
1957 euros pour les fonctionnaires
civils
mais surtout c'est pensions sont
inégalement réparties il faut se
rappeler
il faut rappeler que les deux tiers
c'est à dire environ 63% des militaires
quittent le service sans droits à
pension militaire de retraite
c'est le cas de la quasi-totalité des
militaires du rang et du quart des
soufis des sous-officiers puisqu'ils
sont rayé des cadres avant d'avoir
accompli 15 années de service
au final les militaires français
s'ils partent à la retraite plus jeunes
que les autres actifs partout tu m'aimes
plus tard que les militaires américains
britanniques ou allemands il ne s'agit
donc pas d'un avantage nationale mais
bien d'une spécificité de l'êta
militaire que l'on retrouve dans les
autres pays et qui plus est
contrairement aux croyances en la
matière leur droit à une pension n'est
absolument pas assuré
or ce texte prévoit de retarder encore
plus qu'il ne l'est déjà l'âge de la
retraite la possibilité pour les
sous-officiers de partir avec une
pension à jouissance immédiate après 15
ans de service sera progressivement
supprimées comme pour l'ensemble des
salariés la durée de cotisation
on sera allongée de deux ans en 2016
il faudra donc avoir servi 17 ans pour
prétendre à une pension à jouissance
immédiate
ceci aura inévitablement de conséquence
le nombre de militaires qui quitteront
le service sans droits à pension
augmentera considérablement et ses
métiers qui par essence ne peuvent plus
être exercé au delà d'un certain âge
vous connaître un vieillissement
particulièrement dommageable pour
l'activité elle même et pour les
conditions de vie et de travail des
militaires je voudrais surtout dire pour
leurs conditions de sécurité
merci chers collègues sur la porter
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
président cette fois ci si l'alinéa 3
donc de l'article 16 qu'on oppose ce
qu'on nous propose partant de supprimer
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre est du même avis pour les mêmes
raisons défavorable pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent voter cet amendement veuille
bien levé la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veut bien levé la main il
n'est pas adopté un amendement 797 il
est présenté par madame dati - si vous
le permettez monsieur le président je
défendrai dans le même mouvement le 797
le 798 et le 799 et cela de manière
brève avec un grand plaisir aux cercles
messieurs ministre mes chers collègues
nous l'avons vu tout au long des débats
qui ont précédé la séance d'aujourd'hui
l'un de vos engagements d'autorité de
prétendre que l'allongement de l'âge
légal de la retraite serait l'une des
conditions essentielles pour sauver
notre système de retraite par
répartition vous déclinez ce dogme de
façon intangible et aveuglément et comme
pour les autres catégories de salariés
le relèvement de deux années de l'âge
permettant l'ouverture de droits à
pension seraient ainsi avec cet article
7 également applicable aux militaires
cette application si j'ose dire uniforme
et encore une fois ne tient aucun compte
de la spécificité de la condition
militaire
en effet pour un grand pays comme le
nôtre aux traditions et aux caps
cité militaire établi et
internationalement reconnues une des
conditions nécessaires pour pouvoir
disposer de forces armées efficace et
opérationnel et qu'elle soit composée
d'hommes et de femmes jeunes ou dans la
force de l'âge
certes les militaires ne sont pas tous
affectés à des unités combattantes mais
le ministre de la défense en application
des recommandations du livre blanc sur
la défense et la sécurité ne cesse
d'affirmer son attention d'inverser le
ratio actuel entre les fonctions de
soutien et l'opérationnel
afin de mieux répondre aux exigences de
la projection de nos forces à l'étranger
nous force constable fer de lance de nos
armées doivent donc impérativement être
composée d'hommes de femmes jeunes
qu'il s'agisse des hommes du rang de
l'encadrement ou du commandement ces
mesures de relèvement des limites d'âge
vont vite se heurter aux réalités donc
du terrain car il est pour tout le monde
évident qu'un militaire ne peut pas
accomplir les mêmes tâches physiques à
59 ans qu'à 20 ans c'est pourtant ce
dont il est question dans certains de
ces alinéas dans cet article
et c'est pour cette raison que nous vous
demandons d'apt et notre série
d'amendements merci chers collègues
alors monsieur à porter la vie sur les
trois amendements pour les trois
amendements avis défavorable de la
commission pour supprimer les alinéas
4-5-6 de l'arc ims yeux le ministre
l'avis du gouvernement mais ma vie parce
qu'on est toujours dans un no logic de
suppression merci pas de demandes
d'explications de vote que ceux qui
souhaitent adopter ces amendements
veuille bien levé la main merci que ceux
qui sont contre veuille bien levé la
main il n'est pas adopté ils ne sont pas
adopté un amendement numéro 800 il est
présenté par madame la barre brièvement
je défendrai 800 800 802 pour assister
sur le fait que vous avez décidé sans
aucune concertation avec les intéressés
l'allongement systématique pour toutes
les tranches d'âge des limites d'âge des
militaires
nous avons dénoncé précédemment la
pratique dogmatique que révèle
l'application mécanique de cette mesure
mais nous avons aussi d'autres raisons
de nous y opposer
et revenir ce qui a dit notre collègue
guy fischer car on peut crâne par
exemple que le vieillissement important
de l'ensemble des effectifs de nos
armées auxquelles conduirait cette
disposition ne constitue rapidement un
handicap on en actions tant la
différence qui existe dans ce domaine
avec les armes et amis qui sont d'un
niveau opérationnel tout à fait
comparable au nôtre
en effet nos militaires parce
aujourd'hui à la retraite un peu plus
tard que leurs collègues américains
britanniques ou allemands en août ces
dispositions sera assurément un effet
négatif sur le déroulement des carrières
car elle entre elles et entre 3 en
contradiction avec les politiques
pratiqué jusqu'ici qui permettent une
promotion une promotion rapide des
officiers et des sous-officiers les plus
méritants elles risquent ainsi de créer
un véritable goulet d'étranglement pour
les graver les grades les plus élevés ce
sont des raisons supplémentaires qui
nous incite par ces amendements de
conséquence les amendements 800 800 812
vous proposer la suppression du
relèvement pour certaines tranches d'âge
des limites d'âge des militaires
merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis de la commission
défavorable pour les 800 800 à 806mhz
monsieur le ministre vous même avis mais
le président n'oublie pas de demandes
d'explications de vote si monsieur
d'englos voilà pour cette après midi et
pour les discussions sur la réforme des
retraites
il reste encore de nombreux articles et
de nombreux amendements examinés les
discussions devraient se poursuivre
cette nuit et encore demain
alors qu'une grande journée de
mobilisation est prévue prochain
rendez-vous l'actualité politique et
parlementaire le 19 heures présenté par
pierre henri gergonne est toujours notre
site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur notre chaîne